good morning and welcome to the second
day of NDC conferences and this talk
about typescript decorator's so Who am I
my name is Damian and I'm an independent
consultant mostly helping teams getting
better and working with bad various web
technologies so in this talk will mostly
talk about typescript decorators but my
goal is to just show you how you can
repackage some really well-known ideas
from the function programming world and
use typescript decorators to kind of
facilitate that because I really think
from what I've seen from my experience
that the decorators are really really
underused feature of typescript most
people are especially developers working
with angular they're quite comfortable
using built-in decorators you know for
dependency injection and everything that
angular facilitates but they're also
quite comfortable with you know building
components and building services but
I've very rarely seen someone building
new new decorators and I think that's
that's really a shame because you can
accomplish a lot and make your code much
more cleaner and nicer if you if you use
decorator so just the sort of a set of
stage for this talk before we actually
move on to the mechanics of decorators
and how you can use them and how you can
build new ones I really enjoy let's talk
yesterday about the power of composition
was anyone actually on that talk it was
the first talk in the morning yes they
could we have a show of hands Oh a
couple a couple it was a really nice
talk that the talk about the power of of
composition which is one of the basic
principles of functional programming so
um let's just sort of set the stage by
starting with something fairly simple so
let's let's start with a function called
sq Artie
which should in theory compute the
square root of a real number so if we
say something like result and then ask
you RT 16 we should get 4 do not can you
actually see the stuff happening on the
console or is it is it too small
um I'll just make it a little bit bigger
so let's put this to maybe 20 and then
make that bigger okay so we call the SQ
RT function and with 16 as a parameter
and we get 4 as a result we call it with
9 we get 3 we call it with 16 again and
we get we get 4 okay so how about this
done let's say at some point in time we
decided we would like to add a little
bit of logging to our application so
obviously one way to do that would be to
add that directly inside the SQ RT
function
and then we get exactly the same here a
view apart from actually seeing the
parameters being logged every time we
invoke this this function but I think we
can actually do do better than that so I
can introduce another little abstraction
we can implement a function that would
allow us to lock the parameters of any
function that we that we want so how
would that what would that look like so
we can say log is a function and that
function takes actually a function as a
as a parameter and then it returns
another function as a result and what
what does that function look like well
it takes some arguments and then it logs
whatever these arguments are you can
actually spread this so we get a nicer
output and then we just invoke this
function that we passed in as a
parameter and passed exactly the same
arguments and then what we do with that
well we can just say sqr t is log mass
dot x QR t and we get exactly the same
exactly the same behavior here on the
right side we see 16 being logged in
because there was a parameter and then
we get result of 4 and then 9 and 3 and
then 16 16 and 4 so now we have this
little very small though reusable
abstraction that we can then glue on to
any function we want and have its
parameters being logged in and we don't
have to kind of pollute this function
here the math dot s QR C and add any
extra behavior in there we can just bolt
on this logging feature onto any
function any function we want
okay so this was a really simple simple
example what we can maybe go one one
level up so I remember when I was about
15 they'd kind of demo scene and then
graphics programming was all rage and I
mean this is gonna sound like the
Yorkshiremen sketch from Monty Python
but we really had a slow computers which
did not have any floating point support
so you actually it was really really
slow to do any floating-point operation
like trigonometry functions or square
root or anything like that and when you
do graphics programming square root is a
really important function because you
computing distances all the time and you
call the square root function many many
times so what would typically happen in
in a in a demo was that if you have lots
of friends you would initially show a
greetings page where the name of your
friends will scroll indefinitely while
you were in the background precomputing
all the possible results for all the
possible parameters of the square root
function so that you can reuse it reuse
it later on and typically you would save
that into an array and then look up by
index and avoid the computation
altogether which would kind of make the
whole thing possible or bearable now
there's that that that's probably even
counterproductive because you have much
more powerful CPUs that can you know
compute square root in a couple of clock
cycles but it was kind of all all all
the rage then so but I think the idea is
still applicable maybe not in that
direct form but we'll see later on an
example where that for actually that
approach might actually come useful so
now we'll try and build another little
reusable abstraction to kind of deal
with that idea of remembering the
results of a particular function in
vacations so how would you going about
that well we can again build another
function and maybe call it memorize and
he's also a function that takes function
as a parameter and then returns another
function as a result so what does that
resulting function look like well it
takes some arguments again and then we
actually have to make this a bit more
elaborate in this case but then before
we return this new function as a result
we need to initialize a little store
where we keep track of all these results
of these computations so we can say
something like results is an empty
object and then here we can say let's
add some property called key which we
would use to look up into the results
and for the purpose of this
demonstration let's just say that that's
Jason string before i args so we just
string if I whichever parameters are
passed to that function is as arguments
and then we can say if this results has
a property with the name key then we
just return that and otherwise we then
need to do a little bit of work we have
to say results key is what we call the
function FN okay
FN arcs so we store we invoke the
function past the parameters and
remember the result inside this results
object and then return return the same
the same value as a result okay so let's
let's see how would this work
what connection so for the time being
I'm just going to replace this with
memorize and then I'm coming gonna
comment out these ones and I'm actually
gonna add this log-log stuff back in
right so what we have now is this sq RT
function with two Bolton's added on one
for logging the parameters and the other
one for cashing or remembering all these
intermediate results so when we call it
with 16 we still get four as the result
and we see number 16 being being logged
as a parameter when we call it with 9 we
see 9 being Lankan logged and 3 being
returned as a as a result but when we
call it with 16 again we only get the
result but there is no log which is
exactly what we want because what
happened is this memorise decorator of
bolt-on actually remembered what the
result was when we call the function
first time with number 16 as the
parameter and now we just get the result
straightaway without sq RT being invoked
at all right so now we have these two
little bottoms that we can reuse any
time any time we want and obviously now
you get the idea how this whole thing
works you just have these functions all
the way down pretty much like Turtles
you just keep nesting than one one in
each other we have the original function
which actually does some useful work and
then we have all these bottoms that we
apply on to it by passing that function
as a parameter to other functions and
then passing these results again as
parameters to other
so this this bit of nesting here is kind
of starting to look like that pyramid of
do that you might for example get when
you work with callbacks callbacks a lot
so um might be worth investing some time
and coming up with an abstraction that
makes this kind of bit more ergonomic
and easier easier to work for you to
kind of avoid avoid nesting so there is
actually a well known abstraction that
helps you do that and it's called
compose that's basically the idea behind
functional composition so we might say
we want to have a function called
compose which is also a higher-order
function because it takes function as
parameter and returns function as its
all but this one is a bit more
complicated because it actually takes an
array of functions as as parameters so
we're gonna call that offense for
example and then the function that we
return as a result is the one that takes
some arc and then that's what well we
need to start with these offense and
then we want to reduce them but we want
to reduce them from the right-hand side
not from the normal left-hand side so we
couldn't use the reduce write function
which takes two parameters the first one
is the reducer function which is has a
result and a function
might let's let's do this let's make it
simple and then we'll make it more
complicated later so let's just call
this arc let's just do it for one arc
that that that's easier to understand so
reduce right take the reducer which just
passes the previous result on to the
next function and passes the arc as the
initial value for the accumulator
function model I do wrong here curly
brackets but it should not mean thank
you kindly
thank you kindly okay cool
so now we have the composed bit and then
we can change this a little bit we don't
have to have all these nesting we can
just say sq Artie he's composed memoirs
and look and then math asked you party
and we get exactly the same exactly the
same result but what's better about this
is that it's kind of more ergonomic you
don't have to have all these nesting
when you invoke the functions you've
gone from kind of going deeper and
deeper and deeper to just going more to
the right more horizontal you just
specify which functions you want to
compose and then give them the original
function you get you get a function back
that has all these all these bottoms so
this is a bit unfortunate the way we've
implemented compose because it won't
work your function has multiple
parameters so what we would actually
want is something like this you want
these to be arcs and then pass
the args and then pass the arcs here and
return a little array here and then take
the first one
you
like so yeah so now with this flavor of
compose you would actually be able to
compose functions where the original one
takes multiple multiple parameters okay
so so this is kind of a fairly standard
way to how you compose functions in in
in JavaScript most functional libraries
would already have these things built in
things like memorize compose log
throttle debounce
and many many others but let's now see
how we can repackage those ideas in a
slightly different way and use
typescript decorators to come up with a
really really economic way to add these
bolt ons to our to our code so what we
have here is an example to how you
implement a decorator in in typescript
and this is basically a decorator that
does absolutely nothing so it just
decorates a function and allows you to
invoke that function and return exactly
the same result as the function did
originally so as you can see the
decorators are just plain functions as
you would expect and they are exactly
the same kind of functions that we've
seen on that little demonstration before
they're functions that take functions as
parameters because this descriptor dot
value would be nothing but your method
for example in your class and then
return some other functions as a as a
result so pretty much exactly exactly
the same the same idea and it's exactly
the same structure but let's let's see
put this into into practice with kind of
more elaborate example so here we have
the log decorator which matches exactly
what the log higher-order function did
on that little demo that intercept any
invocation of the method that you
decorate with this decorator and then
logs whatever the parameters are when
the function is invoked and then returns
exactly the same
exactly the same result so we have this
little example here a simple angular
component it's not too really important
if you not familiar with angular this
should be fairly easy to understand
what's what's going on it's a component
that has a button and when we click on
the button we want to store hello world
in this message and then render that on
on the screen but because we've
decorated this event click call back
with the log decorator we expect the log
statement to appear in the log when we
click on the button which is exactly
what happens I have a little demo here
to show you that so when I click on this
say hello
you actually see world being logged on
the console every time you click and
that's because we log all the arguments
before we actually invoke the original
invoke the original function so this is
actually quite similar to sort of monkey
monkey patching in in JavaScript you
just hijack the original method and then
replace it with another function that
does a little bit of extra work and then
invokes the very same original function
returns the same returns the same result
so we've seen that these decorators are
nothing but JavaScript functions they
just plain plain functions and you just
use them like so you decorate whichever
method or a class you want to enhance
and add some extra that's some extra
behavior so this is a really simplistic
example because this log decorator
cannot be customized in any particular
in any particular way but because these
decorators are just functions you can
actually then implement what is called a
decorator Factory so you can have a
function that actually returns a
function that is a decorator itself and
what would that look like well we would
use it like like this so this log is now
no longer a decorator it's a decorator
Factory because you need to call it
first in order to get the decorator back
and with this little trick you can now
pass some extra bits of configuration
initial initialization to your to your
decorator so here we have an extra step
of indirection we have a function that
returns a function that returns a
function so this one is the factory this
one is the is the decorator and then
inside this options object in our case
we just pass the name of the component
or the unit that we want to appear
inside inside the log and then when we
log we take options dot name and then
concatenate any other parameters
afterwards and then when
I click on this button here we actually
see logged em a component and than any
other parameters that are passed to then
passed on to that function and that's
actually really nice because you can
then customize your decorators and have
them configured in a very particular way
that matches your exact exact use case
just by using this little trick where
you actually have functions returning
decorators instead and because again
these are just normal type script or
JavaScript functions these parameters
that you pass in they not necessarily
have to be data you don't have to be
passing in your strings and objects or
whatever its parameters it's perfectly
legitimate to pass a function as a
parameter as well so for example just
for the purpose of the illustration we
have another decorator factory for
logging where we pass the format
function as a as a parameter with the
idea being that you can exactly specify
what and how you want you want locked so
for example here the format functions
takes arguments as parameters and then
outputs logs the name of the component
and the current timestamp or any other
parameters that you passing on to that
function and then that's what actually
ultimately gets logged on to the console
so if I click on this button here we
actually see the name of the component
the current timestamp and all the
parameters that were that were passed in
so you can obviously make this as simple
or as complex as as you like because you
have the full power of JavaScript and
JavaScript functions available available
to you ok so that was the kind of simple
simple example
so the next one is just wrapping that
very same memorized function we had on
that little demonstration and turning it
into a decorator so the basic idea is
pretty much exactly the same we
intercept the function invocation keep
track of the previously previous
invocations inside these results object
literal compute the key check if we have
the value and then store it otherwise we
just return the very same result
obviously that that's not very it
doesn't seem to be very useful for
memorizing things like square root and
normal calculation but what it does come
useful is in cases where you need to do
some IO operations to make things happen
so even though this is very non
idiomatic angular I think it's good
enough for the illustration so hey we
have a component that is trying to make
some asynchronous HTTP requests so it's
trying to use this API for fetching the
message of the day and then rendering
that as a promise inside inside this
template so whichever the message we get
back from the server we render inside
inside the template and let's say we
only want to fetch the message of the
day once inside our application so
ideally you would want to move this onto
the service or any other more civilized
way of managing the state inside your
angular application like ng rx or store
or something like that but for now it's
just inside the component and we can
just annotate this method here the fetch
message method with the memorize
decorator and what that we do is ensure
that the side-effect the asynchronous
call only happens once you can request
for this message as many times as you
like but the real HTTP request would
only be made once and you would actually
cache the result of that invocation and
all of that is possible
cause we use a promise I promise here
because promise is a really nice and
useful abstraction because you get a
value or an object as a as a result and
then you can just catch that object and
store it inside that results little so
we can actually see a little demo of
that so we have this refresh button when
we click we get a message and we see the
HTTP request happening but when we click
again nothing nothing happens because
exactly the same promise would be
returned as a result and no side effect
is happening so this was a really
primitive implementation of memoization
but again you can make this more
complicated by turning this into for
example decorator Factory and adding
some placeholders for configuration so
for example just administration one
thing that we might want to be able to
do is specify the expiry time so we can
say you can cash this value you can cash
this promise but for no longer than one
second so if someone else asks for the
same operation within a thousand
milliseconds giving back the same result
but after that just forget about this
value and make make the request again
and we do that just by allowing an
option to be passed in we the name
expires in Milly's so this would allow
you to specify after how many
milliseconds the value expires and then
if you remember that together with the
value itself then you would be able to
detect when the value had expired and
then make the call
make the call again so we can actually
see this in action
mmm so if I click on this other button I
get a message and if I click again I get
another one but if I keep clicking a lot
I only get to see one at most one
request
one more request per second and this
message is only updated at most once
once per second so you probably noticed
that we don't show any progress status
while we are loading the message it is
quite a common thing to do inside any
any web application and when I look at
work with different teams and look how
people do that that code tends to become
really really repetitive like every
single component you know regardless of
whether you work with promises or rx or
any other obstruction has a lots of
duplication when it comes to kind of
showing progress messages and spinners
and whatnot and what happens typically
is you pollute your business code with
all these orthogonal or non relevant
concepts that's where decorators come
really really useful because you can
isolate that behavior and implement it
once and then just bolt it on and if you
use it anytime anytime you like so what
we have here is a slightly more complex
example because we have a little combo
we have a decorator and we have a little
component that is the loaded component
itself so the idea is the decorator the
loader decorator would still have pretty
much exactly the same structure as as
before a function returning a function
returning a function
but what happens inside the decorator is
we capture the promise that's returned
by the result of this asynchronous
operation and then we we done it
and when the promise is when the
operation starts we raise a flag inside
this object here called operation in
progress and when the operation either
succeeds or fails when the promises are
the result or rejected we remove that
flag from this object literal here and
then that allows us to show the spinner
inside this loader loaded component
because the loaded component is binding
over this object literal and only
showing this little span or icon if the
operation if the operation is in
progress so you now have this little
combo of the decorator and the component
you can decorate any method you want and
then stick the component wherever you
like and when while the operation is in
progress you will see the spinner -
spinner showing this one is kind of bit
more elaborate because we also allowed
to specify the name of the operation so
because you typically have multiple
things going on inside the web
application you don't want to have maybe
a single loader for all of it you want
to have separate loaders for different
for different operations so that's why
this seems a bit more complicated that
maybe should be and then we can see a
little demo so how would we use this
well we again have a component that has
a method called fetch message be the
same thing that returns a promise
promise as a result but we didn't
decorate this method with the loader
decorator and say the name of the
operation is fetch message and then we
put the loader component itself and say
show the loader
if the operation called fetch message is
is in progress
and then when we click the refresh
button if you have a really young and
quick eyes you should be able to see a
little spinner appearing on the right
hand side of a button while the
operation is he's in progress so it's
quite common when testing this type of
code is a synchronous code that you
would you may want to prolong the
duration of certain operation so that
you can verify the user experience and
and then how long it takes what does
your application look like when you have
slow requests going on so that's why
this little decorator called delay comes
comes useful so the idea is this we
would like to have a little helper like
this that we can then stick onto any
asynchronous method and say well can you
actually delay this execution for let's
say 2 seconds so that I can verify that
you know the spinner is indeed shown and
then that I can that my application
behaves behaves correctly cuz maybe your
API is a super quick and super fast and
you never get to see the spinners when
you develop so in sort of development
mode this this is something that might
be quite quite useful so how would we go
on about this well again we have this
little utility function called delay
which just delays a promise to be
resolved after specified number of
milliseconds and then inside the
decorator we delay the promise for the
specified number of milliseconds and
then perform the original function
invocation and return that as a result
so basically just using promise training
to delay the invocation
of this of this API and then we can see
a little demo so if I press on this
refresh button after two seconds we get
the message back and we show the spinner
we showing two spinner all that all the
time right so now that we have our
loader and our delay another common
issue that happens when when people
write asynchronous code at least from my
experience is that they don't really
understand how promises work and then
break the promise chain and end up with
operations that return promises that are
never neither resolved nor know rejected
or alternatively you may want to limit
the duration of your asynchronous
operations to a certain amount of time
so imagine you have a really long
promise chain that does lots of things
asynchronously but you will want to say
if the whole thing does not complete
within ten seconds I want you to mark
this whole operation as as a failure so
how do we go on about that well again we
can build another custom decorator
called timeout with the idea being that
we can say we can then decorate any
function we want and specify time or
duration in milliseconds and if the
operation happens with it within that
specified time we would get exactly the
same result if the operation takes
longer we just get a promise that is
rejected with the let's say reason
timeout exactly after that amount amount
of time so how would we go on about that
but again we have a factory that takes
Milly's as a parameter as a
configuration and then returns the
decorator itself we get a hold of the
method we invoke it
here and then we raise that promise that
we get back as a result against a
promise that would timeout after let's
say a thousand milliseconds so we again
invoke this helper method called delay
which gives us back a promise that times
out after time email is and then we
failed that promise and then race it
against the original original one what
would that look like so if we have a
little example here that is now using
all these three decorators so we first
delay this by three seconds and then we
time it out after 2,000 milliseconds and
we also show the loader obviously we
would expect this to fail because this
would never complete within the two
seconds that the timeout is going to be
waiting for and that's exactly what
happens if we try this little example so
if we click refresh button after
approximately two seconds it would fail
because we don't get to see any message
here but you can see that request
ultimately still happened and you
actually succeeded and we got the
message back because the resulting
promise failed in theory we actually do
get yes we do get the error here saying
unquote rejected rejected promise so now
we have quite a few of these little ball
tones we have the one for adding the
logging to all our functions to
memorizing the results and showing the
loaders and we also have a way of
delaying certain asynchronous operations
and also specifying the cut of time for
when the operation should ultimately
ultimately fail so this really allows us
to keep this business-related code
really really simple and really really
focused around heavy parts so you we
only program against the happy part and
we get the decorators to handle
all these other nasty error in boundary
and boundary conditions like you know
getting the errors things timing out and
and so on so one thing that also becomes
quite repetitive when when I get to work
with different different teams is how
they handle errors you see the error
handling code spread out all over the
application code and all over the all
over the business code and and that's
another perfect candidate for something
that can and should be handled by the
decorators and then make less repetitive
and then deduplicated so how do you go
on about this well this is actually
quite similar to the whole example with
with with the loader we have a combo of
a decorator and a component so we have
the error decorator that is only
checking if the promise that is returned
by the original method is rejected and
if it is rejected and all we do we just
push an error onto this array of errors
and then inside the error component
itself we just render whichever errors
happen during the execution of our
application so as a little example
what we have here is a fetch message
method that is trying to talk to an
endpoint that does not exist this is
this API / missing so our expectation is
that this operation would fail and
hopefully it would be picked up by the
error decorator and then rendered by the
error component that we this we show
there we show here so we click on the
button the error happens because we get
404 as a result and the little error
message is rendered here if we click a
couple of times we get multiplayers
which we can then dismiss and whatnot so
these this example is fairly simplistic
and it's not probably the best way to go
on about handling errors but it
illustrates the point is it's good
enough to show to show the idea so we
intercept the call detect the case when
the error happened register that
somewhere and then that gets picked up
by another component showing what and
why the error the error happened
so hopefully this gave you some ideas
how you can improve your code by
identifying all these orthogonal
concepts inside your application things
like error handling loading caching and
and so on and then wrap these things
into either higher-order functions or
method decorators they're just kind of
different way of packaging the same old
ideas and recycling some really
well-known concepts from functional
programming world some other ways where
you can we can use this is obviously
dependency injection because that's
exactly how dependency injection is
implemented in in in angular but you can
do that with your code as well if you
use things like nodejs or
javascript on the server this would be a
good candidate for implementing the
transaction transaction management
inside your application code another
quite common place where I use this a
lot is I tend to write lots of load
tests or stress test tools using using
nodejs and it's really useful to have
some sort of reporting to you know how
long the requests are taking how many
failures you have how many successes you
have then your 90th percentile and and
and so on
so one really neat way of doing that is
basically build a decorator that you can
instrument your functions that do all
these asynchronous operations and then
use things like rx and then turn those
into streams and then compute
continuously any kind of statistics that
that you're interested at and then you
can render those on the screen or save
them in a file or create reports from
them and and what whatnot
but it really keeps the whole the whole
thing very very clean because there's a
really strict separation between
gathering statistics and all this
application application code another
another useful another idea where you
can apply this is to analytics so if you
use Google Analytics or any other kind
of analytics inside your application it
is very easy to just implement a
decorator that interacts with the
third-party analytic systems and then
sends events across when certain things
of significance happen inside inside
your application and the really nice
thing about that is that then that
becomes completely encapsulated and if
you want they want to change to a
different analytics product all you have
to do is just three implement your
decorator and all your application code
remains exactly exactly the same other
things that kind of could be worth
packaging into these decorators are sort
of other
[Music]
higher-order functions like you know the
bounds throttle and so on
also things like retries in in in this
talk I didn't really want to use rx
because I don't know maybe people aren't
experienced with rx enough but all these
ideas are also very very applicable if
you use our X and they are actually
quite a fair bit simpler to implement
because our X already supports the
piping and chaining all these operators
so you can what you can do is just
encapsulate a certain combination of
operators into a new decorator and then
just glue that on any kind of operation
that that you want so implementing
things like you know retries becomes
super super trivial it's literally just
adding a single decorator without
changing any other part of your of your
application right well that's all I had
for today hope you enjoyed this and you
got some material to think about and
then some ideas to try later on when you
develop your your own code thank you
very much
[Applause]
you